today we're gonna talk about one of the
best minerals for achy joints I'm
talking arthritis not just
osteoarthritis but even rheumatoid
arthritis there was a study done I'll
put a link down below double-blinded
placebo-controlled pretty hardcore study
you see one little trace mineral okay
showed a 71 percent improvement with no
side effects
boron born has a trace mineral what's a
trace mare what's the difference between
the trace mineral and a mineral trace
minerals are basically minerals needed
in smaller amounts okay like selenium
and iodine those would be trace minerals
but boran's function is an enzyme
cofactor it's a helper in certain
enzymes specifically to make cortisol
and other steroid hormones
now cortisol is an anti-inflammatory
what is the main remedy they give all
these patients with arthritis especially
rheumatoid arthritis they give them
prednisone
what's prednisone it's cortisol it's an
it's one of the main anti-inflammatories
born is also good postmenopausal for
women because it enhances estrogen and
testosterone those are two steroid
hormones so women can get osteoporosis
sometimes if they have an imbalance in
certain hormones or on can help make the
bone stronger by enhancing these two
hormones estrogen and testosterone
boran's involved in vitamin D metabolism
Brian could potentially help with
erectile dysfunction why because it
enhances testosterone Lauren has a
natural anti microbial effect you can
help toenail fungus it's like a natural
antibiotic
I mean think borax borax is kind of like
a cleaner right well it can clean up the
microbes in your body Boren helps
calcium-magnesium absorb better into the
bone so if you have arthritis especially
rheumatoid or even osteoarthritis this
is a no-brainer very inexpensive
I would recommend six milligrams once a
day and see if it can help you
hey guys real quick I have a new healthy
keto eating plan for you just go to dr.
Berg comm it's right on the front page I
put a link down below download it it's
free check it out